people must ask you all the time how do
you do it how do you do it yes and I
would think now we live in this new
world of the internet yes it's gonna be
it's made people very cynical about
magic like I had a girl come up to me
the other night after a show and she's
like hey Justin she goes I know magic is
fake and I was like me too I know as
well that's my job but she said it as if
she thought that I thought I was a
wizard and I'm not a wizard
I don't have special powers so if I did
I would not be doing magic for a living
but I think that just because magic is
fake doesn't mean it's not a great art
form I have a metaphor I think that
magic is like breast implants right okay
right we all know they're fake but when
done well can give you a feeling of true
wonder how big you were just gonna stop
it
magic is like breast implants anyway
coke you know Google makes it to
Whoville I would say Google people must
go because Google is so good at what it
does people aren't used to ever needing
to not know anything but my job as a
magician is to do things you don't know
I try to give you mystery Google Rob's
mystery so Google is to magic what
lights are at a strip club carpeting
okay I feel like we finally connected
yeah
and takes on the mystery out of it how
she was right there with you I could
show you because I'll do a trick right
now it's an okay trick but then I'll
show you how it's done if that's all
right basically what Google what Google
does you're doing what every magician
touch the back of one you're not allowed
to see if the eight of clubs I can see
okay yeah there's a giant I don't know
okay so eight of clubs I've seen this
before so we shuffle it up a little bit
here and Andy in a moment I'm gonna have
you light a lighter I have a lighter all
right I'll say free bird okay and you
light the lighter deal gonna hold the
deck in your right hand right hand
perfect in addition to the deck I have a
nice ripe black balloon and I just watch
I just tap it very subtly and then Andy
like kind of like enjoys magic Harry
magic way you're holding waiver it's
real weird free bird watch we just heat
it up and perfect one card penetrates in
the balloon the eight of clubs okay so
that's an okay trick okay pretty good
trick it's called the card and balloon
trick but the problem is that if someone
sees that I know if they go home and
google it they'll probably figure it out
cuz that's that is where I learned it
but the point is is that it doesn't it
doesn't feel good to know so I'll show
you how I did it okay okay so you picked
the card it doesn't matter Ricardo
depicts the eight of clubs I put on the
top of the deck and I kind of gave it a
little shuffle like this right makes you
think I'm losing the card in the deck
blood sure but Andy notice that from the
back look better the top card doesn't
move yeah yeah just pull the front side
is total chaos right back side quite
orderly so by the end I was adding fun
up here but I just said look a girl
and then I handed Conan the deck but
after I hand him the deck I palmed off
here to clubs I palmed it yeah there's
no Santa feel this people this is the
truth okay you help get into that boat
you have to back up I started so far I'm
like yeah okay but just got it into the
balloon okay so while you hold up the
deck I then take the eight of clubs and
I palm it against the outside of a
balloon like this okay do not use a
clear balloon by the way oh I see I do
that which actually does nothing
highlighter pops the balloon it makes
the card jump toward your fingertips
that's how the trick works that's
fantastic it's okay I know I like no
I've never seen a magician illusionist
what have you do a trick and then say it
here's exactly I don't work kind of a
bummer that's the thing Conan if you
want I can make it magic again watch
here's the alternative handling okay
that was a bad card in balloon
[Applause]
you